before pursuit of wonder was a youtube
channel it began as a book a book that
got turned down by publishers and
literary agents the inspiration for the
book was born out of the sense that so
many of us including myself feel as
though we have been given a carcass of
life of meaning in which important
aspects of how to potentially live
fulfilling authentic lives understand
the mind and the self introspect and
deal with the often disquieting
absurdity of it all are rarely if ever
truly addressed and discussed
i wanted to see more of these topics
engaged with in an enjoyable and
accessible way and i wanted to
contribute to this through pursuing and
sharing wonder through exploring
interesting and thought-provoking
philosophical ideas i was repeatedly
told however that without being a known
author or public figure that this
particular book would be a tough sell
and so since i couldn't get traditional
distribution and marketing i took the
issue of getting my work to the world
into my own hands
i took the manuscript of the book and
began creating videos out of it and then
started this youtube channel with those
videos
pursuit of wonder has now developed and
evolved into something that is beyond my
ability to even comprehend
in full circle under the pursuit of
wonder umbrella i have now begun writing
and publishing books and today i have
just released a brand new book that
essentially encapsulates the purpose and
vision of that original book that
catalyzed pursuit of wonder it is my
collected works of fully updated and
revised essays on various ideas and
schools of philosophy titled the art of
living a meaningless existence ideas
from philosophy that changed the way you
think which you can find the link to
purchase in the description below
[Music]
as soon as we gain self-consciousness
and an ability to inquire about the
world we are fated to ask questions like
how does the world work why does it work
this way what does it mean to be me to
be alive and how do i deal with these
questions and their seemingly
unanswerable nature
in more recent times a history-long
effort of constructing towers of meaning
with collective and religious
foundations have seemingly begun to fall
more and more
many of us are now left with a sense of
the individual need to construct our own
homes of meaning out of the debris
this of course is no easy task
however philosophy and literature have
helped provide me with a way to do so a
stack of blueprints and materials to
consider and build anew throughout
history and across the globe there are
thinkers and writers who have understood
and thought deeply about the underbelly
of existence they have and continued to
attempt to confront concerns thoughts
questions and doubts about life and its
meaning without the tiptoeing and
masquerading often found in other areas
of popular culture and self-development
i have found that the conversations i
have had with these individuals through
their books and art separated by time
and space of who most i have never and
can never meet have changed the way i
think in ways that have been essential
to the quality of my life
the art of living a meaningless
existence is an organized collection of
essays from the channel that journey
through philosophy in an attempt to
share these ideas and conversations
ideas that grapple with the complexities
of life and the increasingly relevant
problem of finding meaning and what
appears for many of us to be an
inherently meaningless existence
the book pulls from concepts in stoicism
existentialism nihilism absurdism
buddhism taoism and more attempting to
create accessible and thought-provoking
takeaways that change the way you think
about yourself existence and how to
appreciate the absurdity of it all not
only have the essays been improved and
revised but i have also added additional
essays containing deeper insights about
the overarching subjects and why i
personally find them valuable again if
you're interested the book is available
now through the links in the description
below it is currently available in both
paperback and ebook formats
pursuit of wonder started as a longing
to relentlessly pursue my curiosity
toward wonder and truth then it turned
into a sense of obligation to create the
most interesting and useful content i
could based on what i found and now it
has turned into a source of great
meaning for me
i hope you find something in my new work
or in my work more broadly that assist
you and your own process of discovery
just the same
if you do choose to grab a copy of the
book thank you sincerely in advance
regardless of whether you do thank you
sincerely for watching and for
supporting the channel and any and all
the ways you do your viewership your
subscribership your sharing of the
content your messages comments moments
of time and thought and all the rest i
truly appreciate it all
into the future i hope to continue to
create and build on this channel while
also beginning to more frequently create
and release other forms of media and
longer forms of work like books digital
downloads and whatever else the world
has in store
all your viewership purchasing of my
work and support in general help
contribute to the realization of these
goals and the evolution of the pursuit
of wonder and so again as always thank
you so much for watching in general and
see you next video